welcome everyone to chess in the 21st
century so if you're following the
second part of the Grantchester just
ended in Belgium so a lot of great games
even though it was rapid and blitz I
have to say it's amazing how many great
and games were played in blades and in
rapid and so much endgame knowledge and
such good technique it's so many
attacking games it was just amazing to
see so we're gonna start with this so
just a calculation puzzle so block to
move it's a last move why took upon so
kuranes playing Carlsen yeah
so take so rootsy 491 looks like a
strong idea but I can just go route k1
and take your night so just do 5 and 24
is unstoppable thank you
so I'm saying yeah so this happened and
white resigns because you only have one
check you cannot really capture anything
even if you capture I still have made a
game over
okay so this was our warmup so now we're
gonna move on to so one of the most
impressive games I was played was
between maxima charlyk Robin Anant and
this was from round one and this was
announced first tournament in the
Grantchester this year he didn't play in
Paris so it just started the tournament
and he played a really beautiful and
amazing game I'm not gonna run through
the whole game I just want to get to the
position so it was a pretty double-edged
position so it's not on that five kind
of annoying because this Knight cannot
move piece is gonna come to e7 but at
the same time the King side is a
compromised
it's a 94 so what do I do here right so
Bishop h6 you cannot capture because of
the four so a none play win ce7 so he
ran I took on g7 so what would happen if
Bishop takes yeah yeah
so you remove the card you move your
night with a temple and now you're gonna
take on just seven or take the Queen and
checkmate so night took so we want to be
able to use this F file and also we want
to be able to get the Queen to the game
so what's stopping the Queen from
getting into the game this pawn right so
if you're gonna play Knight after you
need to calculate it out so night f2
King takes looking out yeah so you want
to go night h4
I understand I cannot take it um I still
wanna go night at five so after the game
mainly interview Anand was just showing
this lines like here like it was going
to all of them so fast and it's very
impressive because this is a rapid game
like we moved 28 but why not they
probably have like 10 minutes agent just
like calculate everything else so fast
so what happens after okay after you so
if you take on f3 you want to keep this
king in this zone so the King cannot
just run away so real Gary King after
you without your options so night h4
it's a very forcing line so I can get
dream and then let's try to do without
moving so look after a king after a
night h4 can get three only move by g2
right so I have to go to d2 so yeah
so let me show you and this is the line
that you actually calculated so night
age form so here you have two options
here either Bishop a5 or you can go
native for so Bishop a5 so Knobloch has
two moves
that's re White has two moves you either
have to go to d1 or c1 let's say I pick
one of them let's say okay so actually
this is what he calculated so 91 so what
can white him Queen b3 it doesn't quite
have a thread so you have something far
more active remember D 2 square is
covered Queen f5 and now all of sudden
black is the one getting made it 26 just
mates but why it's still black still has
a way of stopping it because the king is
on c1 so it's kind of a pattern so it's
gonna involve your night so you want to
cover the F file so when I take you you
can block it's a tactical solution
because I'm at the red right to choke
and meet to move mate
enough to it's not good enough - enough
- and if you check now I can just block
so this position is very tactical but
unfortunately for block after Bishop a5
the king can simply go to d1 mm-hmm and
once you take all the squares are
blocked from the Queen and now black is
the one getting made so this is a reason
why he rejected this line so here it's
also possible to go here of course
there's no king d1 because I will check
and take your queen that okay so this
position it's not so clear we can just
so it's gonna go on so it's not clear
why black is winning on a white black is
even better so he didn't find a better
move
so keep in mind so the king is in a very
bad square so the King doesn't have a
lot of places to go to basically is
stuck so we have this bishop we have
this pin our rookies in the game your
queen is hanging yeah oh
you dream so Quincy - let's say I go
rogue if 122 was in fact plate very
beautiful more so the key is to keep
this king in a central square so we're
using this pin we're using this pin so
it takes and even though there are two
pieces for the rook it turns out that
King just doesn't have a sub square to
go to so for example if you try
something like this simply mate if you
try Queen B 3 so I'm kind of made just
no squares to go to so in this game you
actually white plate Queen e2 so this
should be simple
yeah and the King has to live the Queen
alone and it turns out even though this
looks very scary for black there's
really nothing because the rook alone
cannot do anything and these pieces are
actually kind of awkward because the
bishop cannot move the knight is stock
and the nidus looks like it's doing
something but in reality it's not really
covering any important squares so the
game went on for a few more moves and of
course at a high level like this this
kind of games don't go on for very long
so why do we design so there's 95 move
of course inside and I remember during
interview and he was asked did you see
it was of course I saw it
but former five-time world champion it's
not gonna miss something like that ok so
I have a few games some of them I really
want to go over at the other ones if you
don't have that time it's fine
so same round two round one carvanha is
blinked Apollo suit Apollo had really
been struggling in Paris which was the
first half of this part of the
tournament and he did actually this
whole year he hasn't been doing really
well so Khurana also didn't do too well
in Paris
he's rapid and bleed skills are not the
greatest but I mean he's still of course
a very strong player so much so same
thing he sacrifices his rope so what's
the point of the sacrifice right it's
not a unlike the last position where I
like just sacrifices like few more moves
and white is just busted this is a very
good practical decision especially when
you're playing long time because all the
pressure is on your opponent to find
defense for you your moves are very
natural so in faster time control this
is very important even if maybe you're
in a worse position if you can find most
quickly when your clock is running in
your plant has to find something of
course the pressure is on them so white
sacrifices a rope but all these pawns
are hanging and this kink is in trouble
so actually white does have a threat I
just want to take this e5 pawn and this
diagonal is not safe so let's say if I
make a random move just to pass the move
and I actually have threats on the
diagonal your rook is hanging if you
take I'm gonna take the rope and you
lost a lot of material so black didn't
react well which is nor of course
natural when all of a sudden the
sacrifice comes at you and you have so
many options and your opponent is not
really doing something very forcing to
win the game it's very easy to make an
error so he actually played Rock d7 this
rook
so better move is something like this
covering the seven rank so just to go
down the most forcing line so now rook
g8 is an option because we defending
this rook so bla white cannot just play
down the rook forever so white has to
prove they sacrificed a rope for
something so if white tries to do this
now it has how many pounds four not
three pounds which is of course a lot so
getting this one and now the position is
not so clear because this King is quite
exposed so if you start pushing your
pawns or you start getting very
adventurous I can always have a
perpetual and of course I still have my
extra night so white has to be a little
precise so rook here of course I again
covering the seven rank and maybe trying
to play a move like Queen g8 so what to
do so this position is already very
difficult to play for block yeah yeah so
we're gonna take a pawn so if route game
6 is gonna be similar to the game so
King g8 so I really like White's move
here so here you definitely don't want
it so here your opponent actually wants
to take and then bring the knight into
the game so you definitely don't want to
take because the night is gonna come
into the game just helping your opponent
yeah rookie six very nice move because
what's the idea behind rookie six yeah
so we have a tie squared bishop so a
bishop is covering the dark square so
we're gonna need our queen and the light
squares so you have a thread of playing
rook e8 so if your opponent takes the
key is now he cannot walk because of
this pin so King f8 I really like
White's next move to
your subjects are very good bringing the
bishop from the side sub g5 so Queen
here
so why did we put the bishop on g5
Bishop 87 so before you do anything in
this position one important question you
want to ask yourself does black have a
way of getting out of this so black is
really tight down there or cannot move
the King Stach the Queen doesn't have
too many options because there's Queen
f6 so can like somehow someway get out
of this not really right because if you
play Queen f7 I'm just gonna check you
and you cannot block so what does it
mean for white does white have to rush
with Queen f6 or something forcing no so
we can't do something to improve our
position so what can we do
yeah either if v or t4 and you start
rolling the spawns because if you're
gonna end up exchanging everything it
wants your pawns to be more far advanced
so you can make the Reds with those
pawns a 5 let me see if you play Queen
f7 all right you know so Knight tries to
get back into the game so keeps pushing
when f7 so now block actually has a
threat and to check and mate so now you
cannot just do whatever so yeah of
course if I'm sorry so of course if you
block yeah so I have to get out
so white can white by force is already
winning so question can you what happens
if you take on g7
right so there is a perpetual threat so
we have to be very careful so let me
show you this
if g3 perpetual if back well it's like
you're getting made it so jittery and
you have to do a perpetual so you don't
want to do something like this and then
get painted all right so so clean so
queen b7 was plate so cool
so if Queen c7 what if I go King where
should I go I have to go King e6 let's
say so your queen is on the wrong
diagonal so what does your Queen need to
be for this perpetual not to work right
doesn't have to be on b7 just has to be
on this diagonal so when those checks
come at you you can play g3 and then
your queen will block so if Bishop takes
have a perpetual already so first you
need you want to take now if you take
now okay so what do you want to do so
first we have to put the Queen on the
diagonal okay so how are we gonna do
that so you want your Queen on this
diagonal so when your opponent starts
checking you can go play g3 then the
Queen will come and block and then
you're gonna be up like three funds okay
so Queen b7 putting the Queen on the
diagonal the King goes back okay if the
King goes back same thing he went to
front and then
now you don't want to take the Queen
because you're gonna reason so keep the
Queen on the diagonal with the temple
Queen c6o you're on the diagonal King
goes but now you capture because if
checks that's it
game over
um
they're so takes okay so someone so this
is simple so I can easily calculate out
the window ready right because when you
check me from the 7 rank I have to go to
afraid to protect the Queen so you can
decide where you're checking me from so
Queen B 7 double attack King here and
now you're just winning the piece and
you're up way too many pawns so again
very good practical decision so of
course maybe block could have defended
better but if you're playing this
position and then you don't see a good
way to improve you think the game is
maybe gonna end up in a drought you know
you put the pressure on your opponent
that let your opponent figure out if you
can make a drawer which is gonna
collapse and was like this so all the
pressure is on your opponent that's the
best situation to be in so Wesley still
had a really great tournament but he
finished 2nd played very solid but this
game was just very bad came by him so
night after day here
so this part I don't want to focus too
much on this I just want to get to the
position I'm talking about an h-pipe so
this h5 move happens a lot against this
structure even if like is behind in
development but here I think it just
doesn't make any sense because like is
way too behind in development and
there's no way all of a sudden why he's
just gonna get under a tug and get
checkmate because it's pcs are just not
active enough they're not really doing
much and yeah I mean that looks more
natural to me so um I'm not sure why he
decided to play like this but the
advantage of black has the center is
still closed so so white cannot just
punish block for this bad King in the
center so it takes each form
Knight goes back
because c6 was hanging let's say you go
g6 I'm gonna take nope
and you lost your work and this actually
this fianchettoed Bishop is of course a
very annoying piece so rook c8 so now
why decides to play very active ghosty
form so why do form
yeah so I'm asking why did I decide to
play before so if I take what's your
plan so what why doesn't have anything
immediate so what is white going to do
yeah so white is playing for initiative
because like is still behind in
development this King is still in the
center so white wants to quickly take
out his pieces and do something in the
center because before like castles let's
see you have to play g6 otherwise it's
just not developed so look if t1 and
Queen here maybe you can harass the
Queen more and then put your Bishop on
the diagonal so again a long-term
sacrifice it's not like white is just
crushing through but black they don't
take it so I've got a little scared so
Bishop d5 and again in the faster time
controls like accepting this kind of
sacrifices are very scary so in a long
time controller can sit here think about
for like 10-15 minutes figure out okay
if I take this pawn am I getting killed
or am i okay
but then when your opponent plays you
know 25 or like by now I probably have
less time move like this sacrificing a
pawn and you see all these pieces are
coming out it's not so easy to take a
pawn like this but instead what he did
was a lot crazier sufficiently 5 c4 so
takes takes Queen d4 I mean it the way
the black is playing is very reckless so
now actually the position has opened up
even more
so you have two pieces on when you have
two pieces under attack like what's the
general rule what do you want to do yeah
you want to move one of them with a
temple captured so then just wants a
piece so what do we want to do
they have someone temple move attacking
the rook and black doesn't have time to
capture this bishop because it doesn't
make any threats so takes 56
so this King is just horrible quite
meter I'm mostly looking a block so
Queen Victor is actually very bad for
because 25 and I'm threatening weight
when I 5 you want to meet me it's all
about Queen D so on
yeah so the thing is this king is not
really going anywhere so you have time
to activate your pieces so Queenie five
so five four so all your pieces are
coming out with a tempo so your tiger is
going to be stronger because it
developed all your pieces and this King
it's not improving anytime soon so here
know what has a very simple wing so you
have this pieces on one diagonal see it
do another one on this diagonal so the
Queen doesn't really help you because a
piece blocks you so what's the other
yeah so you need to check with the
bishop those are the Queen checks the
nine will block if a bishop check stand
this is the King get stuck a g5 bishop
see it's a of course I think he wrote
know everything of course he cannot take
because you have meat so he played King
g7 and just you want a rope nothing
fancy just maybe a bishop and of course
white want the game so kind of a
miniature kind of not a good way to lose
a game okay so we don't have that much
time left so there was a game I really
wanted to go over okay let's look at it
from lights point of view so what's
going on in this position Luke and links
are very hard to do it and there are a
lot of rook endings and some of them
were played great some of them were
misplayed and it happened because the
rock endings are very tricky but before
we find moves or before we do anything
we need to understand what's going on in
this position right
yeah so from the white point of view
white house is a pretty advanced pawn so
it's the idea is kind of the same so
block is eventually gonna have to end up
this rule to be it's gonna end up giving
up this work for the pond and white is
gonna do the same but the problem for
what is what it's because I still have
two versus one so if I can take this
pawn and then give up my rope there is
no way your route can subdue pawns so
it's very important for a white not to
lose this pawn okay so what did them so
rook e1 was played King here
and then if after is it still tours as
one I and actually kind of just helped
me dare to because after it's gonna come
with a temple so let me show you for
example if you just push your pawn and I
take of course if you put your upon
you're just closing if you try to be
very clever then I'm just gonna play
here and you cannot stop the punch so
what is White's defense rook g1 so you
have to defend it it's very important
not to give up this pawn so if your
opponent plays f3 you're happy because
you're happy to give up this rock it's a
corner pawn and your pawn is for advance
you're just gonna start pushing it so
something like this doesn't scare you I
mean okay you can play here and just
such an easy draw not even close
so after this what if I play I go after
this guy
give me five let's see here so again you
cannot just allow me to come and take
this guy's so you have to go after my
own pawns
look you won thank you for let's say
okay if I take the same drop one versus
one so here
uh-huh
there was the difference between these
two positions right once you push then
you're gonna have okay four so if your
opponent also just cannot waste a lot of
times because you have counter play so
for example after rook g1 what if I go
King III go straight forward move so a6
king of two you wanna go okay one then
I'll take the rook e1 was played it was
similar to what happened in the game
yeah that's what happens in the game so
I'll come back and show it but let's
find a way so that doesn't work so let's
figure out a way how to defend or
actually let me show you why it didn't
work and then we'll find so in the game
he played rook t1 so we got to the same
position so this is the position you
want it right okay so now King g3 so
this is the key move okay six King V
five on how to stop the pawn
right if you're gonna root a - I mean
okay you can still play this then you
can play this Queen endgame but no
reason to make things complicated so you
can you can just play a rock h2 and just
simply give up your look from the side
yeah yeah this is exactly what happened
and black won the game so let's go back
to this position so rook Jiwon we found
the move and then we said King g3 so now
we have to find a way to still hang on
to our pond but King p3 you're on the
right path because you need to get rid
of this annoying group that's attacking
you
so King FC is a threat so we need to
find a way to deal with it so
unfortunately we don't have this trick
like this idea with rook e1 looking for
that it was tried it didn't work because
this annoying work is here constantly
attacking this fun and we don't have
time to push our own punt so King b3
let's say that rook goes somewhere so
recap on is a possibility but I think
after this move I still have time to
come and take it
so let's find another way to defend the
pond
yeah
yeah exactly you've got rid of the rope
from the second-ranked now we're gonna
defend from this side something like
this and now I'm just gonna start
pushing my own fun so now you don't have
a choice you have to do this and make a
drum so very nice so this game is very
instructive and I thought this part was
very interesting first you defending the
pawn from behind sorry and then when you
switch up your ideas and then you start
defending the pawn from the side but the
most important thing to realize in this
position how important this pawn is and
you have to hang on to this one
otherwise you're gonna lose the game
because your own pawn is not fast enough
to stop this rook from taking the pawn I
think this is all I have for today we're
out of time but if you want to check out
the games I'm highly suggesting it's so
many instructive and games both in Paris
and both in Belgium even in rapid and
bullets time controls there's such high
quality games some of them not all of
them some of them for like we said that
the Wesley games not a very good game
very high quality games even with the
mistakes you can learn so much from them
you